Hôm vô nổ nghiêm trong lửa xảy ra tại nhà máy xảy xuất phá ngoà,
ở quận kêu kinh ra đa băng Áng Dra, Prades, miền năm nổ.
Hình như thà mi mốt người tị bản và như người khá bị thương.
Khó kể xảy xuất đại phương trong số các bạn nhận có một số vụ nướng,
những người bị bảo nứa đứa truyền tới các bạn viện lên cả điều gì.
Truyền hôm địa phương truyến vụ nổ xảy ra, kìa gấu khoảng 30 đình bỗ mấy công nhận đăng trộn và tự nổ.
Để sản xuất phá ngoà, phá ngoà là sản phẩm vụ biến tệ nổ đặc biệt trong các sịp lẽ di ngoa li và đám cưới,
nhưng các tây nạn tại các cơ sử sản xuất không hiểm.
Thôi lên quan đến đi phạm quy định át toàn và công tăng sản sát lòng lèo.
Cánh xát và cổ chiến nạn điểm phương nổ tiền hành điều trà để làm sống muin nhìn cuộc thay.
Và vá vô vụ các biển pháp át toàn phòng người ở chung tương lai.